this morning in our series protecting
the planet we're looking at how new
technology might give America's aging
coal and gas power plants a cleaner
future that technology is called carbon
capture and if new EPA rules take effect
most power plants that burn fossil fuels
may have to use it or face getting shut
down Congress has allocated billions of
dollars in subsidies to expand the use
of carbon capture but it has faced
powerful criticism as well senior
National and environmental correspondent
Ben Tracy shows us now why some say that
carbon capture is actually an expensive
and misguided distraction in the fight
against climate change
this is the national carbon capture
Center and kind of our main mission here
is to test carbon capture the national
carbon capture Center sits along the
banks of the Coosa River in Alabama
it looks a bit like something Willy
Wonka might build if he ditched
chocolate for carbon dioxide how long
have you guys been testing carbon
capture here so we've been testing a
total now of over a decade John
Northington is the director of this
department of energy research facility
it's attached to an operating coal and
natural gas fire power plant run by
utility giant Southern Company
so this place is like a very large
laboratory yes it represents about 135
000 hours of testing and over 70
different Technologies coal and
gas-fired power plants generate about 60
percent of the electricity in the U.S
and are the country's second largest
source of Planet warming greenhouse gas
emissions carbon capture stops CO2
emissions from going up the Smoke Stack
they are separated out with chemicals
and usually injected and stored
underground does the technology work yes
the technology does work what percentage
of the carbon do you actually capture
generally in the neighborhood of 95
capture but so far what's worked in the
lab has not worked so well in the real
world the Petra Nova coal-fired power
plant outside Houston was the first and
only commercial plant in the U.S to use
carbon capture it had technical issues
high costs and was mothballed into 2020
its new owner is now attempting to
revive it it's definitely not a silver
bullet MIT professor Charles Harvey says
carbon capture and storage or CCS
doesn't make sense because it now costs
less to build new renewable energy
projects such as wind and solar than to
operate in existing coal plant a dollar
spent in the renewable technologies will
avert a lot more emissions than CCS will
he argues carbon capture just allows the
industry to keep burning fossil fuels in
fact the carbon captured at the
petronova plant in Texas was used to
extract more oil from the ground in a
process called enhanced oil recovery the
frustrating thing is that there is an
easy solution and that's uh that's to
stop
using fossil fuels we have the
technology to do most of that right now
and I don't think we should be
distracted from that he does believe
there could be a role for something
called direct air capture sucking Planet
warming CO2 right out of the sky to help
avoid runaway global warming this is the
biggest version of this that exists on
the planet yes this plant in Iceland run
by Swiss company climb works is the
world's largest operating direct air
capture facility we visited in 2021 the
day they turned it on these fans suck in
air CO2 is separated out and then inside
these Huts it's injected into the ground
where it's permanently stored in rock
formations every tongue up CO2 that's
removed is a ton that's actually helping
fighting climate change and not
contributing to global warming but it
can only remove about 4 000 of the
nearly 40 billion tons of CO2 two humans
are pumping into the atmosphere every
year larger facilities are now being
built including this one in West Texas
I'm excited I think there's a tremendous
amount of potential John Northington
believes carbon capture Technologies can
help even if they're not a silver bullet
if you take that off the table then
you're trying to solve the problem which
is a very complex problem with one arm
tied behind your back for CBS mornings
I'm Ben Tracy in Wilsonville Alabama
I mean that's a great piece from Ben
Tracy's reporting is terrific on this
subject the reality is with climate
change there are only hard choices you
can either change the economy and our
Energy System politically people don't
want to do that we've seen that or you
can bet on human Ingenuity in an
invention that somehow cleans up the the
climate that seems to be politically
more palatable which is why you're
seeing a lot of people banking on carbon
capture yeah we see people are working
24 7 to make it better we still have
such a long way to go to get it right
and we have to get it right no Planet B
as they say